hi everyone both here but many more of
you who are online welcome to another
edition of our conversation series uh
sponsored by the Yale Institute for
Global health I'm delighted to welcome
everyone uh to this event this hybrid
event
in addition to the Yale Institute for
Global health or ygh today's event was
sponsored by The Walker fund of the
MacMillan Center
the first cases of covid-19 appeared in
Pakistan in February 2020. and as one of
the most densely populated countries in
the world actually serve several areas
are very densely populated in Pakistan
um it the country was fairly vulnerable
to adverse impacts of this new pandemic
and like any new pandemic like many
countries in Asia particularly South
Asia
during today's event which is as you
know those of you who have been
following these events follows a series
of conversations over the last three
years on various Global health related
topics but one strand that has run
through a lot of these conversations
certainly not all of these conversations
is the pandemic response starting with
Dr Anthony fauci in 2020 going through
Dr Tedros from who the UNICEF directors
four directors of CDC directors of CDC
and and so on and so forth and leaders
from around the world so in this context
we will discuss the challenges of a
pandemic response in Pakistan which is
very interesting in the sense that it
has a federally devolved Health System
but there are several functions that are
centralized as well uh and and there is
a specific need in a pandemic to make
real-time data-driven decisions we will
outline how these challenges were
overcome including lessons for around
the world on how to respond to Future
pandemics unfortunately this is not the
last infectious disease related event
that we'll be seeing and one misnomer is
that it's a hundred year pandemic but
100 Year looking back looking ahead it
will is likely to be there is evidence
that it is likely to be more frequent
with that in mind I'm very very pleased
to introduce our honored guests Dr
fessel Sultan who's the former Special
Assistant to the prime ministers on a
prime minister of Pakistan on National
Health Services regulation and
coordination or in short he had the
portfolio of the federal minister of
Health in Pakistan
Dr Sultan is an infectious disease
physician and has been the CEO of the
largest cancer hospital in fact uh the
largest cancer hospital Network in in a
large country like Pakistan for several
years
um and uh you know in addition to more
recently serving uh in his government
capacity he's a graduate of of the King
Edward Medical College uh in Lahar but
did his residency here in Connecticut at
Uconn and had uh if I can say so a
formative rotation at Yale where he was
inspired to do infectious diseases and
some of his mentors are still at Yale
and credits are inspiration in this
institution's inspiration uh to to
change the trajectory of his career he
also trained in infectious diseases uh
at Washington University School of
Medicine he serves on several high-level
International and international fora
including Pakistan science for
foundation Pakistan medical research
Council and the HPV human papilloma
virus advisory committee for the World
Health Organization he also served on
the board of Global Alliance for vaccine
and immunization or gavi the vaccine
Alliance welcome Dr Sultan thank you so
first we'll start with a broad question
how did Pakistan do in responding to
covid-19 and and how did how was
Pakistan's uh response uh somewhat
similar to and what were some of the
differentiating features compared to
other low and middle countries in
sub-Saharan Africa in South Asia and
Southeast Asia more broadly and in the
Middle East right so I think I mean you
know some of it is subjective obviously
I think generally we were able to do
well but there were a number of measures
a metrics that one could think about or
talk about that would make one think
that we came out of it somewhat okay or
better than some other countries
um I think very broadly one could look
at things like mortality things like
overload of the Health Care system or
how far and how fast the economy
recovered post covered or during it and
so I think a number of these measures
point out towards uh somewhat um I
wouldn't say easier time but a better
outcome than some other countries that
that went through comparisons are odious
and it is very difficult to make across
especially across countries with
difficulties different systems and and
political structures but for similar
size countries with similar challenges I
think I would say that many other large
Federal structure countries ah did
suffer quite a lot and relative to them
I think we came out a little bit ahead
so in terms of yes so you write that in
terms of data collected by our world and
data and others there were mortality
um sort of metrics that were lower Etc
and sort of independent data validation
has shown that if you can triangulate
those data
Etc obviously there are data issues in
any pandemic but but broadly speaking
um sort of there have been you know some
of those uh features there
in terms of take us behind the scenes
because one of the lessons this pandemic
has taught us that it's not necessarily
the technology it's the the operations
how the public health response is
managed stickers behind the scenes what
were the Leadership Lessons as a public
health leader you learned in responding
to the pandemic I think some of the most
important lessons uh or if I could call
them Leadership Lessons or you know on
lessons in general as well that came out
of this and they certainly relate to
some of the behind the scene behind the
scenes efforts that that were made
relate to the fact that coherence
and data driven decision making and that
too in such a way that is uh well
communicated well received and then the
ability to follow through on many of
those recommendations and you know
mandates or guidelines or restrictions
that that we all came about with so the
ability to do this in a coherent
data-driven consistent and uh flexible
way was the key lesson that came out of
this when we started out
um I think within Pakistan as in across
the globe there was confusion as to how
to deal with it people had seen what had
happened say for example in China and
Wuhan where they had the ability to shut
down you know an area or a city or a
province and yet continue to function as
as a country then we all saw images and
news and numbers coming out of some of
the first European countries and then
Iran next to us that that suffered
heavily
through mortality and and how the
disease spread and how it it pressured
the Health Care system so this there was
indeed confusion and a whole range of
diversity of opinion on how you could
deal with it on one hand there were
people
who were the naysayers who felt that
this was all some you know a problem
that didn't exist the nehalis and then
on the other hand there were people who
wanted very early and very harsh and
very blunt measures which would be very
destructive for the country as a whole
and so you had to find not just a middle
path or an equal equidistant middle part
but but a response that one would tackle
the pandemic but would also allow life
to go on so so this sweet spot did not
necessarily have to be right at smack in
the center but it had to be data driven
and driven by by the science of it and
it was finding this by creating data
flow networks
creation of expertise uh sort of pools
the ability to analyze some of this the
ability to scale up whether it was
oxygen or ppes or beds or the raw supply
of oxygen to predict where the next you
know know outbreaks would be and then to
of course ensure that vaccination
happened so all of this was a complex
dance that that had to be done and I
think the most important lesson out of
this is that we may be a federal and
many other countries may be federally
devolved diverse countries but for a
pandemic response
we must have the ability for a cohesive
Central response so a little bit more
operational details so I think I think
this is a really good sort of overview
in terms of tell us a little bit about
the the your Emergency Operations Center
which was called the ncoc the national
something right
coordination how did you get the the
data in a sort of in a country how do
you use Geographic systems where and a
little bit about uh you know specific
Supply chains issues like oxygens Etc
that how you estimated that need and how
did you respond to that in real time
right because as I recall Pakistan and
had strains on this oxygen supply chain
but it never had real shortages and that
kind of a cycle when when there are
shortages and then people sort of uh
keep it for their families in their
hospitals Etc and that kind of stuff so
how were you able to avoid that right so
let's let's begin at one end so the
first of all was the the governance end
of it and the ncoc got formed really as
what does that stand for the national
Corona operations center yeah and so uh
so so the the command and operation
Center for Corona came into being when
the National Security Council figured
that it really was a threat to National
Security and for for the government to
be able to have a whole of the
government approach which connected all
the federating entities had expertise
marshaled in had a civilian head of the
you know the the response but have a you
know a military arm to help them with a
lot of the follow-up
procedures that were required and to be
able able to connect to not just the
provinces but elements and entities
within the federal government so that
was the governance piece that got fixed
with the formation of the ncoc the
Cadence was it met every day for hours
at a time and it was all data Centric
talking about data so one of the most
important bits to be done was to create
a real-time flow of data for example
testing for example fill up of beds the
number of oxygen beds the the PPE is
required so all this required that we
had efficient data flows and databases
that talked in real time so we connected
all the nearly 200 Labs 173 I think was
the max that were for example testing
for PCR for Coronavirus and to connect
them either directly or through the
provincial dashboards and so we were
able to piggyback on to what existed as
the ID IMS which is the polio dashboard
added a few fields to it in real time
and so the data flow started to become
real time and accurate then of course uh
the other important thing was we needed
to know where space was or where you had
actually spare capacity because we
realized that the epidemic would not be
even you will have surges in one place
and relative spare capacity perhaps in
in the same town without being aware of
it so this visibility of the resource
required a resource management system so
over 3000 Healthcare institutions were
connected to it in real time gaining a
number and you know how many people were
how many beds were available how many
oxygen beds how many wet beds and so on
and similarly ah an infrastructure for
the information system for vaccines had
to be created all of this got helped
tremendously and I have to tell you this
because all Pakistani citizens have a
national digital identity all of us have
a number and so all tests that were done
were tagged to a national number all the
vaccines that were given were tagged to
a number and so this the ability to
capture this data was important they had
other layers that were added that really
helped us suppose a geographic layer so
if we we knew where somebody was and
based on census data we could tell where
there were hot spots in in complete real
time and therefore that helped us to
have nuanced and targeted those
so-called smart lockdown instead of
shutting down the entire city so in a
sort of quick breathless we have told
you how to how we were able to utilize
some of the data and technologies that
existed we used geolocation we also used
how people's Geographic address matched
up and not only that was that used for
contact tracing but and for Hotspot
detection but also how we scheduled
people for for vaccination so we would
schedule you close to your house or your
address to a center that was near you
and of course we went down by age so all
this was helped by having that
information at a central place so so
elaborate a little bit more on the the
so-called smart lockdown especially in
early phases of it how was that
different from you know the blanket
lockdowns Etc and what enabled you to do
uh those kinds of prevention measures
obviously later in the pandemic you you
know you didn't do that especially after
the vaccine became available uh but but
in the the relatively early phases how
did you switch to that strategy and
right so so the first lockdown was it
wasn't terribly smart on a number of
occasions it wasn't Smart in the sense
that it was not targeted uh entire
provinces got shut down or large cities
within provinces got shut down this
happened on the 23rd or the 24th of
March 2020 and happened more as a
Cascade of shutdowns and I was reminded
almost you know you you that that famous
line as the first World War break out
and
um looking out the prime minister's
window I think it was a treasury
secretary who said in the UK that you
know the lines and the lights out are
going out all over Europe and they might
not see it lit over their lifetime and
that was almost the feeling some of us
got that you know almost a Cascade of
shutdowns were happening and we really
did not know how and when we would be
able to walk out of those
but that was more a reactive phenomenon
once that happened
we got to work and said look in a
country of 220 million people spread
over thousands of miles we cannot be
having this blunt approach
and we were able to figure out the
presence of the disease because it was
tagged all those 200 Labs or nearly 200
Labs that were contributing were
mandated to actually capture the the
computerized national identity number
and therefore we knew by geography as to
approximately what areas were hot spots
but not only that we also had
geolocation information because in
addition to the number we were also
capturing the cell phone number so we
could tell approximately in an anonymous
fashion where the
hot spots were and then for contact
racing obviously the contact racing
teams in all the four provinces in the
six uh or seven federating units had the
ability to do contract racing based on
uh that geolocated information so once
we got through one or two cycles of this
we realized that we could use heat maps
for the entire country and those heat
Maps were then communicated out to the
provincial entities who then could act
on it in a very sort of smart way so the
lockdowns became very tight you know few
neighborhoods few streets even and
without shutting down the entire city
and paralyzing life so I think and this
continued almost till the end each time
there was a surge we were able to say
okay fine this is where the surge is and
within the city this is where the you
know the the worst part of the surges
and whether it had Direct Mobility
impacts
or it actually altered Behavior through
messaging
is unclear obviously hard to ascribe in
sort of in a dynamic way but I think all
of these things had an effect
good so look you you are a physician
physician executive physician scientist
uh but you know in a pandemic by
necessity a whole of government response
is needed and and the whole of
government is headed by politicians so
any lessons uh you know in this private
sanctum about now
we're being recorded but but any lessons
um about dealing with politicians and in
Pakistan you know said the context has
different provincial governments from
different parties there was a sort of a
prime minister is a prime minister
there's it's a different person in
charge now
um and so so how did you deal with that
and what are some of the Dynamics uh
that are illustrative of that
interaction so just to test out the
whole thing and to test everyone's
nerves and ability to work with everyone
else there was a full rainbow of uh
colors as far as the parties were
concerned so almost each province had a
you know different government from a
different party and so that was one of
the initial difficulties uh people
singing slightly different tunes and by
Design so this is the other bit by
design a federal government is more
worried about the overall economic
impact whereas provincial or local or
state governments are more worried on
the impact at a more local level so by
Design almost by default their angle of
direct I mean angle of view is slightly
different they have different
perspectives so to merge and bring
everybody to the same place required
the usual things
conversations Reach Out
professional to professional
peer-to-peer conversations so some of us
in the ncoc were able to reach out to
our professional colleagues that were
advising the sin government or the kpk
government and where they'll there at
least it was the same PTI government and
to other colleagues across the country
so one of one was this conversation this
reach out this this cobbling together of
opinion and Views that was one
the other bit of course uh was that the
ncoc was headed by Mr Assad Umar Assad
was a fantastic colleague to work with
he was the planning Minister had worked
in the private sector for a major food
company and had been been politics for
10 years and so he understood both sides
of the of the divide and I think he was
able to have the the centrality and the
coherence of this discussion he had
private
um you know
relationships and and knowledge of all
the politicians and the political
entities that existed in the Federation
in the federal entity as well as in the
provinces uh so it was difficult I
personally had an easier time in that
sense that I had tremendous uh trust
with the Prime Minister having worked
for his hospital for 25 years so there
was a peculiar advantage that not so
that's not so easily reproducible for
everyone but I think that was a personal
advantage that I had the trust of the
the chief executive but I think overall
regardless of that you have to gobble
together
these conversations these unions and a
trust Network that eventually got built
and was very robust
so you
think to your other role uh which I
would say your day job which is a
physician and a physician leader at a
major sort of network of cancer
hospitals which is the shakath khanam
memorial cancer hospital and and the
research center
um
describe your experience running and
almost setting up a major tertiary care
entity rightfully there's been a lot of
focus of global Health on Primary Care
Etc and obviously no country or region
can have a claim to a robust health
system without a robust Primary Care
System but obviously you know things
like cancer have happened and they
require major investment in tertiary
care hospital hospitals so set the stage
for for our colleagues here what were
the situation of Cancer Care before the
The Entity was established what are some
of your lessons
from you know helping
establish that and expanding that that
hospital and now the a network of
hospitals
so mercifully for these two years that I
was in the government I was on
sabbatical from here so I wasn't wearing
both hats or else I would have gone
completely off the deep end but um so my
uh
um
I started working at shop as soon as I
moved back from the US this would be
1995. and my initial role was that as an
infectious diseases physician and I
waited myself into our I think life and
luck and happenstance took me to the
chief executive's position
um off note I actually had no uh formal
managerial or administrative experience
or uh background or formal education
background so it was a bit of a chance
that the board took on me and a bit of a
chance I myself took on myself
so I think through this time what I
would if I could summarize this I think
the the most important thing that I have
seen through shogothanam is the fact
that the board had very complete Clarity
of mission that hasn't wavered there
hasn't been Mission creep they haven't
confused themselves into what they are
all about it is about cancer and it is
about having a tertiary Care
Organization and it is about making sure
that there is access to the poor that
the the fundamental pivot on which the
hospital was made was the fact that you
needed to provide access to those that
cannot afford it and so all through the
hospital has remained true to that
mission
things that I've learned along the way a
lot of it I ended up using and I think
they came in extremely handy during my
time in government
were things uh about again about
collaboration about humility about
understanding that your responses and
your plans change about being data
driven about having very important
information and Technology backbones at
shakathan we've had an electronic health
record a fully automated electronic
health record since 2005. uh and then on
a homegrown one at that so all of these
things
require the ability to work with people
and and work with all sorts of people
and I think those were some of the you
know key Leadership Lessons that I was
able to
um and to learn and continue to learn
even today where
um the the the
mission and focus of the hospital
remains that person that child or that
adult who is otherwise not able to
access quality cancer a care and to
provide them with a top class place
where there is absolute even handling of
their care it does not matter we really
do not care if you are paying or you're
not paying as far as the institution is
concerned everybody's handled the same
way some some of those lessons also came
in very handy when we actually rolled
out the the vaccine in Pakistan and
making sure that it was completely Fair
across the board
so interesting so we will go into the
the phase where we will take questions
from our online and in-person
attendees we'll start this time we often
start with in-person audiences we will
start with online folks we already have
a few questions but others are welcome
who are sort of here uh in person uh to
come up with your questions Etc so there
were two related questions one was uh
you know obviously it's a large country
you were dealing with provincial
governments Etc but there are large
cities like Karachi like Lahore and
um you know all sorts of municipalities
even smaller ones are pretty large
compared to because it's a large and
dense densely populated country so how
did you interact with them or that was a
sort of a two degrees removed
interaction did you directly interact
with them and the second thing was the
other end of the spectrum and it's
interesting that both of these questions
came together was how did you reach out
so while there is there are highly dense
depopulated area areas there's a long
tail of sparsely populated hard to reach
locations and their major Equity
concerns
in in this kind of a pandemic so how did
you address these two ends of the
spectrum great question
so first of all as far as the structure
of government is concerned as far as the
official position is concerned we could
only act through the provincial
governments so the NCC and the ncoc had
provincial representation and what does
ncos so the NCC was the governing
sensitivity that was the you know the
national Corona committee which actually
was chaired by the Prime Minister and
had the chief ministers as part of it
and the the membership from the ncoc sat
on it as well so that was the upper
governance committee and the operational
bit was the ncoc which met on a daily
basis and so it was structured that way
so we had to and we legally have to go
through the chief ministers or the
representatives but um or reach out
there was focused on individual or
larger cities or cities with larger
problems or current problems at that
time so for example in many of the Waves
the timing of the two waves or the waves
were different so for example in some of
in some waves it was Karachi that was
first in Lahore later and the other way
around so our ability to reach out to
these individual cities were through the
district administrations but we always
worked through the chief secretaries of
the provinces so the in our structure
the chief secretary is the senior most
bureaucrat that reports to the Chief
Minister of the province and so we
always reached out to them uh but to be
perfectly honest we would also by
keeping them in the loop in the copy
list we could reach out through the ncoc
to individual District Commissioners or
to the commissioners of the Cities
directly as well where there was you
know so the commissioner is the city
level is the city a city or area or Zone
level you know level highest bureaucrat
and and so on uh we also had to of
course by by default engage all the
relevant line Ministries so if you were
going to talk about say ah convincing uh
you know the mosques to to obtain uh to
create some distance between you know
how how people pray during ramzan for
example you had to engage age to the
ministry of religious Affairs so so the
whole of the government that was the
beauty of the place the convening power
and reach of the ncoc was massive so you
could get anybody in the room real or
virtual and and reach out and that
included the private sector when it came
to
making sure that we had enough oxygen we
we were able within the first wave of
the pandemic we were able to raise our
oxygen production the raw oxygen
production 66 percent by just unlocking
a few roadblocks that existed on some
plants that were either dysfunctional or
did not have one Supply or the other and
to to sort those out so it was
vertically
you know down to the provinces or the
cities and districts but also
horizontally within the federal
government
so it's an interesting question
um but but before that is is there any
question from the in-person audience
yes go ahead we'll take one from here
yeah sure so uh my question is you
talked about the difference between uh
being reactive versus proactive just
looking ahead in time so I know that
there was a big problem in the
procurement and distribution of the
vaccine specially during the onset was
there an effort in Pakistan to create
its own vaccine and was it if yes was it
successful because I believe until this
point there's no local vaccine there
right so the engagement with the
potential vaccine suppliers started in
the summer of 2020 and we actually
created a vaccine experts Advisory Group
that took a you know a survey a view a
landscape view of um the entire likely
chances of what was going to reach the
pipeline and despite this as was
expected was almost all of us could
predict that when actually the vaccines
came on board there would be a clear
Supply issue and those countries that
actually had inherent or native supplies
would end up supplying themselves first
uh this this nationalism or vaccine
nationalism was almost predicted so yes
we had initial difficulties in jump
starting the supply we got some
donations from China and some old
strategic Partnerships worked out there
and that was donation but the hiccup
came when gavi that had been hoping and
leveraging on Supply from India for
example for the AstraZeneca vaccine that
that Supply got disrupted because India
had its own way when a predictably and
understandably they had to serve their
own population and so our initial Supply
which we thought would come from gavi
the whole thing had to be turned around
we thought that initially we'd be able
to deploy through gavi and buy later and
whereas it got turned the other way
around we had to buy initially and then
gavi followed up later
in terms of domestic Supply the one
success we did have was fill in
formulation of a single dose Chinese
vaccine cancino but beyond that we do
not have at this time a national supply
of an indigenously made vaccine whether
developed locally or whether manufacture
of an externally developed vaccine this
is a key Gap that needs to be filled
yeah so let's take
uh thank you so much for coming to speak
with us so my question was on this note
of indigenously sourced vaccines we saw
with poliovirus in Pakistan prior that
there was an issue about the source of
the vaccine and how it came from the
West so I'm interested to hear your
perspectives on how information was
disseminated regarding the vaccine and
sort of how vaccine hesitancy was
perhaps addressed through the N double C
right so um this is an off to ask
question and I'll tell you that while
one can never swear that there was no
vaccine hesitancy that be a
silly position to take but if I could
venture to say that relatively speaking
we had very little vaccine hesitancy or
hard vaccine hesitancy as far as the
covet vaccine was concerned in fact
um I would argue that when we did
surveys as well as when the Practical
rollout happened there wasn't any
hesitancy they may have been laziness
and in certain circumstances where the
vaccine was available and people
required to be reminded or you know you
know reminded of not only the
availability but near availability and
then flipping the thing around and
taking the vaccine to them instead of
asking them to come to the vaccine
Center so of the thousands and thousands
of vaccine centers that were created
eventually we realized no we're gonna we
need to go to them so the mobile
vaccination teams were created to make
sure that there was ease of access
as far as the part in the brain is
concerned which is to convince them you
know the the the the mental part of it I
don't think we had too much of a
difficult time in in making that happen
by and large there was acceptance of the
fact that a vaccine was required we did
use uh many levers available to us for
example we are a young country 25
percent of the 25 a fourth of the
country goes to schools colleges
universities Etc
so he said look uh all faculty and
staff and all educational institutions
need to be fully vaccinated and so that
was sort of an obligation that was put
on then of course they could opt out
through for medical reason Etc but by
and large and the uptake was in the high
90s
similarly for a number of other things
Transportation so for Airlines pretty
soon there was a time when you could not
fly without a vaccine certificate
restaurants and the hospitality industry
was really
encouraged very strongly if I could use
that word to make sure that all their
patrons were indeed vaccinated so all
these levers were used but we never had
hard resistance to vaccine acceptance
and it was a national
um in in the the how shall I put it the
vaccine acceptance or preference if I
will was not based on National vaccine
or source of the vaccine at all the
public formed its own views uh what they
wanted and we could see this on vaccine
centers so we have one country that were
offering seven vaccines at one point and
more or less it was up to you you could
really go get what you wanted and to
keep the entire system flowing and
imagine a country 220 million people and
the entire vaccine Network flush and
flowing with all the vaccines available
especially when some doses were so the
Sputnik for example had dose one and
those two that were different so you had
to make sure that if you had X number of
potential vaccinees that had gotten dose
one of Sputnik that the second dose
which was obviously different used a
different virus Vector was also
available and despite that we I don't
think that that was the major challenge
our challenge initially was the initial
Supply as was asked once the whole thing
got flowing
that wasn't an issue
so yeah there's another one and then
thank you yeah so in thinking about the
national like digital ID number you
mentioned it's it's very exciting
because I know we have a lot of
struggles around that with the in the US
what were some of the challenges faced
in kind of reaching those margin like
those in marginalized Community who's
who might not be counted in that and
what are some of the costs and benefits
of the ID numbers in that context
so the digital ID as you perhaps know uh
predates all of this ah the first
attempts of this were from the 70s mid
70s so almost all of us have had a
number and then that eventually got
transformed into the compute rise number
two decades ago so we've all had one way
or the other National digital identity
the estimates from the the organization
that manages this data is that about
four to five percent of people don't
have it they are either those that are
below the radar haven't bothered to get
it uh or whatever whatever sets of
reasons they're marginalized or
disadvantaged in some way or have never
felt the need perhaps
one was to encourage that those that are
Pakistani citizens and can easily get
that to say well look here's an
opportunity we even worked with nadra
that's the entity that runs this to
create mobile teams to go and actually
register people here's an opportunity
here's the vaccine please get yourself
registered and so on so creating that
ease but then there are populations that
are actually not Pakistani at all so the
largest of those were Afghans and they
have very often an Afghan card and so
that was added as to the list of
eligibilities where you could actually
go and show that and get that done
um beyond that there were other
um you know situations where they were
truly undocumented people and so the the
vaccine database the NIMS as we call it
uh had Provisions created in it to
enable uh vaccine centers to create a
record and actually give them the
vaccine we did not do this initially
primarily because for a massive
deployment of 200 something million
people
to ensure that it was documented there
was no pilfridge theft or or
substitution etcetera that we remained
somewhat true and there was Fidelity to
the the cnic the national ID but as we
went along we realized that you know
we're not going to get out of it without
making sure that it was truly Equitable
and reached all the marginalized parts
of society
um so yes it it had mechanisms built in
to allow people without a digital
identity and we were happy with working
on the edges of a little bit of I
wouldn't say irregularity but lack of
accuracy you can't be a hundred percent
accurate in such a large deployment so
we built that
acceptance mechanism in it
so I have a question from Dr Stan verman
who is online so Dr Vermin just you know
recently stepped down as the dean of the
School of Public Health and he has a
long history of working in Pakistan and
training who are now leaders in Pakistan
within the Academia and the government
as well
um through especially the Sindh
government but also at the federal level
uh folks who went through several of his
training programs uh over the years so
he sort of has a question around that
there in in recent years the pashtoon
population in the khabarpect province
and what was formerly the the federally
administered tribal areas now sort of
they are called settled areas
Etc
um and even in karate it's in the South
as well the population has a recent
history of uh hesitancy and refusal
around polio vaccine
so while there may not be much of a
hesitancy at the national level but did
you have a communication strategy to
preempt or respond to communities that
have refused other vaccines
so I met Dr Verma in just two days ago
at ID week
and we had a brief conversation so I
know him very well by reputation I've
met him before as well
um
the short answer is that
we did not find
the kind of hesitation or refusal that
we find with polio with this vaccine
at all and it was not Regional in that
way as well so in other words the reach
out of these vaccination teams was
easier and for some reason and I I can
conjecture as to perhaps what those
reasons are it had an easier sell it has
an easier acceptance we also tried
to have a mutually beneficial
relationship between two vaccines so
during the polio campaigns per force
because the same vaccination forces out
there we had to pause or slow down some
of the covert vaccine but then we were
very conscious of the fact that other
waves were coming it was very important
to get as much of the population covered
while there was acceptance and before
fatigue or indifference built in so we
would create a situation where would
people would go get the polio vaccine
but also we would they would have nearby
mobile vaccination teams for the covet
vaccine so that if there was acceptance
we could do it so in other we try to
help both of the campaigns by by Synergy
with each other fortunately we were
fortunate that the heads of the Epi the
expanded program for immunization as
well as the head for the polio program
had great working chemistry both became
good friends with me and one actually I
had known from earlier so that that
person chemistry and trust also helped
in synchronizing these campaigns I have
to tell you that for the measles vaccine
though we actually had to hard stop the
covert vaccine because the rate of
adverse reaction for covid for measle
vaccines are higher and therefore the
experts that looked at it said well look
you're likely to damage The credibility
of your covet vaccination program
because of the expected or the estimated
adverse effects that are going to come
from the measles vaccine we did 90
million kids during that time so that
was also a huge campaign so for those 12
days we had to pause the the covert
vaccination so we really did not have
that kind of regional or ethnic based
resistance to this vaccine as we have
seen with polio so another question is
by the way I'm looking at my phone not
because I'm sort of texting my friends
uh is because that that's where the
questions are coming from online
questions so they haven't sort of uh
have developed the technology to
directly transmit it to my my brain chip
um so so there's another follow-up
question
um uh on on you know since you mentioned
polio uh what is the situation so
Pakistan had made a progress around uh
eliminating and near eradicating polio
but we know that new cases are there
what is the latest situation I know that
you you have stepped away from from your
government position but obviously you
know so you know the situation so I have
to answer this one carefully I have less
restraint and a non-governmental
position today but this one I have to
answer carefully
um because of the intense um
polarization of political perceptions
Etc within our country anyway so for a
full straight year and more we had zero
polio cases and not only that polio was
at low numbers but our environmental
sampling also and we were you know we
talked about environmental sampling
environmental sampling also suggested
that we were actually making good
Headway we were worried however from
good data that we knew that there were
reservoirs and those were particular
areas and those had to do with some of
the same populations that Dr Berman was
talking about especially mobile
populations as well as from certain
ethnic groups that have a certain amount
of mistrust and distrust I think what
has fundamentally happened in those
places is that the quality of campaigns
and one can't you know say it any more
delicately then this is the quality of
campaigns
leaves something to be desired
now
there is a slider that you have to move
to reach into hard to reach populations
it is crucially important to have people
from within those communities or else
your campaign is not going to succeed
but when they are within from within
those communities
your Ingress into the stringency the
Fidelity of those campaigns is not as
high as it would be had it been normal
employees that you hire in and so
therefore the chances of fake marking
are of you know of being worried that
okay if they report
um non-vox vaccine acceptance and the
next day the you know because this is
the way it is the next day the Deputy
Commissioner is sitting standing outside
the house and saying well why are you
not getting vaccine so so to prevent
such social interrupt so the Deputy
Commissioner is also a senior level
senior level bureaucrat bureaucrat who's
there so so because it is such an
important topic the government has
raised the heat on this matter and so
therefore the intense governmental focus
on that zone or household or
neighborhood would mean that that
neighborhood might feel that they have
been squealed upon by you know that last
vaccinator who they refuse to and so the
social austerization ostracization or
worse that could happen sometimes
creates these situations where people
will either Mark fakely or will just
report that they've you know vaccinated
so it is the quality of campaigns which
is sometimes poor in these hard to
vaccinate areas where the the trouble
arises it has Solutions but requires
diligence and and continued uh pressure
I'm pretty sure it'll it'll it'll happen
yeah do you have a question okay so so
there was a question at the back uh
um that I saw
so yeah this one and then yeah
thank you so much for coming I wanted to
ask a question more from a policy
perspective
um in the tri-state area in many regions
globally The Fallout from covid resulted
in
a backlog and essentially a complete
moratorium on a lot of routine
screenings such as breast cancer
screenings it's uh Breast Cancer
Awareness Month around the world and
during covid a lot of people were not
able to tackle their disease at the
earliest especially in the United States
and it had a lot of Health Equity
implications I'm very curious to know
how this was managed in Pakistan and
what was the impact
in cancer hospitals where people needed
routine screenings or biopsies and
surgeries not just for the late stage
cancers but for early stage diagnoses
because in the United States an approach
that was taken resulted in early stage
just being tabled entirely which for
people who are diagnosed early is their
best opportunity to tackle a disease so
I'm very curious to know about the covid
Fallout thank you so if I had sort of
another question to a supplemental
question to that so you know you're
seeing in either tertiary Care Facility
are you seeing any data trends that
people are not presenting at a more
advanced stage uh of cancer
um
Etc you know related to that okay so
there are two parts of this question one
the more policy part and the other is
the more sort of the impact of of that
policy if it were I'll tell you that one
of the most important arguments that I
could use personally at the time against
broad blunt and
um
blunt is what I should say lockdowns was
exactly this that on one hand we do want
to save lives forget the economic
argument for a second you want to save
lives but the disruption to preventive
systems to help promotive systems early
detection and just routine care a woman
that's that that may require to have a
C-section and she ends up delaying it
because you know there isn't adequate
care available you know even mundane
stuff like this
uh was this this was the argument as far
as people like myself made and the Prime
Minister as well the ex prime minister
Mr Imran Khan that we cannot do it at an
either or we have got to try to find a
path that allows us to slow down things
where it's required absolutely but to
continue the rest of life whether
Healthcare or other things uh unabated
so overall it did have an impact so when
you have in the initial shutdown that
the so-called lockdown the first one
they were um and we had data that some
catch up immunizations Etc had to be
done or given there were also some
reductions in uh the pickup of
tuberculosis cases for example in our
context that you expected to see and
they were not there and then they did
eventually
um come through so the policy was to
ensure that we could continue things as
much as possible and I just gave you the
other example about measles here we were
the ncoc said well look guys
Dr Faisal Sultan you may be the health
Minister and you have other fish to fry
we are the ncoc we are worried about
um
covid and I would say well look you are
wearing one hat I've got the other one
and I cannot let measles go through or
polio go through so all those campaigns
had to be juggles all these balls had to
be juggled at the same time so as far as
policy was concerned the governmental
policy was concerned it was to try as
much as possible to not heart Services
however as you correctly mentioned
because many hospitals reduce services
and and what ends up got gets thrown out
is stuff that can wait and usually that
is earlier or milder disease of one sort
or the other so it did have impact for
our own hospitals are they have to tell
you because I was away I wasn't part of
that decision in my place but we did not
shut down Services we continued services
and so we did not have backlogs of that
kind various mitigation strategies were
used including remote clinics that the
whole world you know employed
um but at least for shocked there was
not a major so so are you not seeing any
more severe like sort of cases at
presentation okay so there was a
question at the back and then we'll come
to online questions and then we'll come
back to in-person questions hi so my
question is kind of similar category
previous questions have been
what was the impact of pandemic on
childhood routine immunization in
Pakistan and how is Pakistan dealing
first are there any numbers to reflect
on what what is the magnitude of that
setback and what are the strategies that
Pakistan is using right now to mitigate
that setback
so yes as far as through the first
shutdown which was from the 23rd of or
24th of March 2020 for about three weeks
there was a drop in for that time period
but it was transient and it was all
caught up in fact
um if anything the routine immunization
coverage across the country has gone up
the Delta for over a three or four year
time frame this is by Third parties not
by the government is 10 so actually a
lot of people are pleasantly surprised
that despite
um the routine immunization numbers have
actually gone up
I think some of the synergies and this
is interesting some of the can-do uh
when approach or or a winner approach
um uh that has happened because of covid
has really energized some of our vaccine
programs I do think that after kovid
where you know good 90 percent of the
eligible population as of mid-september
had had at least two doses of vaccine so
for for a country like Pakistan where
people expected that this is going to
take years it has actually a leapfrog
you know many more developed countries
so
I think that it will synergize and help
the ri program the routine immunization
program but obviously I'm not in
government right now so I can't give you
the official figures but I do think that
the the the dent was there but it was
temporary so yeah so with gavi and
UNICEF and actually UNICEF and who
estimated in Pakistan was one of the
countries that did not see a major
backslide at a you know for a year by
year basis obviously there was that
backsliding those four weeks you know in
that period
um Etc but the concern a lot of us have
is that you know there are second third
order effects of major disruptions do
you think that kind of
um because there's fatigue in health
workers there's you know the system even
if it it delivered during the immediate
phase do you do you think the
circumstances are such that at least the
the coverage will not drop
um because despite the increase because
of its size Pakistan is one of the top
10 countries with zero dose children
yeah so there has been Improvement but
it's a large country like the other
countries like Nigeria Etc are also
large
um so so do you think things will will
remain at least stable if not improving
in the like in these like this year 2022
where the data hasn't come out in 2023
so I'm going to go out on a limb here
and perhaps this is reflective of my
nature
and optimism but I think
um that it will not be a dip in fact you
may actually see an improvement because
the whole vaccine program got so much
Kudos so much recognition in the country
that I think that their ability to
understand that they are able to provide
vaccines and and deploy vaccines well is
going to be higher I mentioned very good
numbers for the measles vaccine again
you know third party evaluations Etc
will come in and we'll figure out I
think it will not go down and perhaps
will improve but again this is just my
view so there are a couple of questions
here this one and then
uh thanks so much for being with us
today and really
um insightful to think be able to look
back and consider the pandemic uh and
what happened in Pakistan and I have to
say as a always wonderful to hear
encouraging and you've given as a kind
of encouraging picture of Public Health
in Pakistan
um I think probably at the back of all
of our minds is of course the flood and
that impact so can you shift gears and
give us a little bit of a you know I
don't know look into the crystal ball a
little bit and tell us what you imagine
or or expect the public health picture
will be I'm specifically thinking of
dengue now my entire family and all over
Punjab has Dengue fever uh is that that
kind of thing could that be endemic or
pandemic or what what do you imagine are
the we kind of started the conversation
with the idea that there will be more
and more pandemics so what do you
expect participate so my the Hat I now
wear is fully of an infectious diseases
physician
working in a cancer hospital so with
that caveat I'll give you my view
because I cannot give you an official
view I do not have access to those
numbers but let me tell you something
interesting the same room the actual
same physical room and some of the same
infrastructure and people that were used
for the ncoc are being currently used
for the flood coordination I am told
that it is proving to be a harder job
because perhaps of the nature of the
problem but never there is the same kind
of effort is being put in
longer term what will happen I do not
know but I think that at the present
time yes
um for for vector-borne diseases Dengue
in particular I you know we keep
worrying about malaria about what we've
seen more uh perhaps for whatever set of
reasons is is Dengue that's one uh the
other thing that I do worry about is uh
the kind of question that was asked
earlier so in the really flooded areas
because Road networks gets disrupted get
disrupted the nearest health facility
that you're used to going to uh may not
be that easily accessible and and
something you know the other on the
other side of the road is closer or more
practical right now and people are not
used to switching care this way
especially when you're poor and have
have less Mobility those are the things
that I do worry about I think that this
is a space that needs to be watched and
reviewed
um not just for vaccine preventable
diseases or or vector-borne diseases but
also for things which are which we
consider routine in other words
antenatal care nutrition
um just routine care for for illnesses
that if not taken care of in time go bad
uh so that's kind of a very
non-professional I apologize kind of you
but I'm being very careful with what I
say because I do not have an official
role
yeah
so I guess this is the last question
from the audience because we have to
sort of wrap up uh thanks for joining us
Dr Sultan
um we've spoken a little bit about
marginalized communities and difficult
to access areas I wonder if you had if
you could speak a little bit uh to any
specific challenges you may have faced
in trying to access remote northern
border regions like in giljit Pakistan
and um Kashmir
so so just to set the context for uh you
know the question was about remote to
access areas the parts of Pakistan
especially the the ones that you
highlighted are mountainous areas where
especially during the winter months
sometimes the access is blocked they are
nomadic communities that go out to
Meadows for years uh for for months at a
time Etc
um and so so that was the question how
did you you know some specific issues
from that right so specifically let's
address for example as an example
um
I think that we were surprised uh and
and I have to tell you this this was
very much dependent on the quality of
the local leadership especially the
bureaucratic leadership that existed
places that had good chief minister good
Chief secretaries of and you know
dynamic Chief ministers clearly made a
difference and we you could you could
see that it's almost in real time
deployment of vaccines uh provision of
facilities uh making sure that the data
was correct and you know real time and
no gaps were happening so GB in
particular I can tell you uh was
exceptional we felt that they were able
to and we focused on them for vaccine
for example because GB is a trip
sorry I keep
a different country so um so gilgithan
is a popular tourist destination and so
it was very important to ensure that
they indeed were protected so their
uptake was not any worse than the rest
of the country and in many situations
they were way ahead of everyone else
partly because they're the the actual
numbers the population is small but yes
the area is large some of access issues
are there
um we even had to as an example
Switching gears from vaccine for example
we realized that we could Supply the
rest of the country relatively quickly
if they were shortages in oxygen for
example from so you have manufacturers
in South manufacturers in the north and
to move trucks this way and that way but
the Northern areas are snowbound in the
in the in the winter and so it's hard to
reach them so the Strategic reserves and
you know large
um uh reservoirs of oxygen were created
in gilgit baltistan just specifically to
make sure that they don't get uh uh you
know blocked out during
um those efforts so we did not see any
clear numerical differences that we
would that would concern us
one little you know marginalized
population women
so when we started out there was a huge
Delta there was a fair amount of gap
between the upwork between men and women
as far as vaccines were concerned and as
time went on WE this is one metric we
tracked and as time went on it actually
narrowed and we felt that the most
important way to do this narrowing was
to take the the vaccines to them instead
of expecting that they're going to make
the visit men are more mobile they may
be riding a motorcycle Etc going
somewhere reaching and and so it was
important to address these so this was
another number that we felt was one to
Target one to narrow down I do not know
the last number but I know that it was a
60 40 split in January so still there
was a there was a gap
so so before we wrap up a brief sort of
question and hopefully a quick answer uh
and you have been very comprehensive and
crisp in your answers so far as well so
in that same spirit
what are some of the things you would do
differently or the country should have
done differently
um you know Lessons Learned but
specifically what some things are we
learn lessons from them uh there are
other things where they serve as a
control group
Etc so what are the things that that you
would do differently I think one is uh
we should have handled the initial
lockdown a little bit uh more
differently I think I keep criticizing
it I think that's one thing I think the
Nuance could have put in been put in a
little bit sooner but perhaps it was a
bridge too far it was difficult to do
that's one the other one that I think we
could have done differently was
um uh the improved our communication of
the why very often what we were saying
we were doing this okay we are shutting
down schools and then everybody said why
and so the why probably had to be
enunciated better these would be the two
things I think one in the realm of data
driven decision making fine tuning and
better comms so thank you very much and
I will sort of apologize to the audience
I know that there are questions I know
that sort of I I switched off the
vibrate function of my phone because I
learned it the hard way earlier because
you know a lot of the recordings have
this this that little buzz
Etc but I I know I'm getting a lot of
texts with uh with questions people are
not texting me directly by the way we
have someone actually uh sort of
transcribing questions from Zoom uh to
me uh and and we as usual we are not uh
able to answer all the questions or able
to put together put all the questions in
front of our guest but thank you and
thank you for the specific and candid
conversation
um around the pandemic response and for
the rest of you we'll continue this
series uh the conversation series with a
lot of exciting guests uh that are um
that will be coming
um to to Yale uh thanks thanks a lot
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]